oh yeah dudes you know I'm excited about
this I told you that we were gonna have
some heavy hitters on the show and boy
do we ever man it's so exciting
feels like every episode is just getting
better and the studio is getting doper
for those of you watching this on
youtube you're gonna see a very cool
sign in the van I just went for it I got
this dope thing that lights up any color
I want so for the very first episode
with the sign I made it orange like a
basketball for Shaq yeah love it and the
people I got the sign from I just found
them on the Internet they're not
sponsoring the show or nothing but I
just had such a good experience with
them I'm shouting them out they're laser
cutting incorporated and their websites
laser cutting inc dot us yeah there you
go
just had to throw that out cuz I'm in a
good mood I'm in such a good mood I'm
gonna tell you that I power my sign with
rock pals they didn't pay me nothin to
say that either I just love my rock pals
battery stores but hey enough is enough
let's get into it this episode is nuts I
tell Shaq that I'm planning on getting
tits like breast implants and now we're
gonna find out how he handled that
little piece of information ah dude I'm
excited man let's do it ladies and
gentlemen Shaquille O'Neal dude all
right
you know what I should do right now
what's that
I should release that video we shot
cycle I was gonna say dude that song was
like it told me that Shaq doesn't give a
[ __ ] you know it was like yeah you
trying to shake my hand I drag it
through my ass crack and like that
didn't come out the corporate people
thought it wasn't a good idea so I have
it in my balls
I can't even say because it was an
aggressive track dude it was more like a
because
listen you're funny I'm funny but it's
supposed to be like a funny thing but
you don't have people when they hear see
stuff they take it serious oh my god you
should say that
you shouldn't do that but the funny
thing about that they cannot tell us our
class so when we got the video Stevo has
a baby pool in it and he ordered the
producer to put [ __ ] in a baby boom and
he had everybody pee and the baby pool
nobody knew what it was for so at the
end of the shoot Stevo and wee man jumps
in it and start chasing people we met
fastest little man I've ever seen in my
life
he got behind me like a little pit bull
and I was running so fast we just kept
catching up luckily nobody got me but
that man right there was probably one
the best moment I want to thank you for
always making do that well hey man thank
you
we're pretty close to the same age I'm
46 next month
one month from today and I graduated
from high school class of 1992
you were the you were the first pick of
the 1992 Draft 1992 draft and I just
looked up the 1992 draft and it said it
was one it was widely considered to be
the deepest draft of all time at that
time and you were number one tell you
I'm a bad son gun yeah okay so check
this out ah I went to the University of
Miami right you went to LSU there's no
beef there but and whatever my I failed
out so [ __ ] fast man I was only there
for that for that one first year but I
hurt I had this girlfriend right and
then in 1993 I was in my only year there
I had this girlfriend that was your
rookie year with the Orlando Magic okay
now me me and my girl were in her dorm
room in the dorms okay weird
doing our thing we're having sex okay
the TV is behind me I'm just like
regular old missionary style the TV's
behind me and I hear this like
newscaster like maybe it's weird I don't
know what it was but it said it said on
the TV buddies heard and it's the Shaq
attack Shaquille O'Neal like you know
rookie for the ruler of magic shatters
the backboard and in the middle of
having sex I'm like I gotta [ __ ] see
this I just stop and turn around to
watch the TV dude this girl was so
[ __ ] angry she like we didn't finish
man she like get the [ __ ] off me she
wasn't even having it dude I had never
been in trouble with a girl like that
and I'm like what do you want
I had to see that man yeah I see you
hold the record for the most shattered
backboards like seven or eight we
understand it to be 19 you called me
boom high school and then parks I mean
one time I was in Sports Club LA people
ate something that's like pretty intense
to me is that the average NBA career
lasts for 2.5 years four and a half
years and the and 80% I think this is
right 80% of all NBA players are
completely dead broke and in debt within
five years of the end of their NBA
career I mean that's just plain
upsetting and and what I think is so
impressive about you is that you've
really made efforts to help people who
are new in the NBA to plan out their
financial future yeah I try to talk to
him and let him know because you know
like like a lot of time for example I
had a contract that was what
a hundred mil but in real life was not
worth hundred mil it's 50 mil Chuck come
on when I first got to LA I forgot who
FICO US and then I first got to LA I got
a check for twenty billion so I go on
the rolls-royce tour got on step dance
and I look at the guy and I was like hey
how much does this cost 250 and in my
mind I don't want spend 250 for a car so
the guy says to me can you afford it
sunny I bought three cars right there
which is a million dollars which is
worth some money
then I'm riding to Beverly Hills I see a
house near the house in the mountains
perfect 7 min I'm at a house - so it's
been eight million prior like in two
days so then my guy called me said you
know you spent your whole check and then
my mom they know I'm getting 20 issues
that know in California 20 only comes
out to ten point five and just spent
eight million two days you only got two
minute left so after that I really had
to slow down exactly like a lot of times
we could do big numbers and we focus on
the big numbers we were able to move
around like tax family employees flossin
spending and wasting so even though it
says like a lot of guys a book is really
easy to do you know it if people always
say well if I get a man I'm a keeper no
cuz one amazing baby is five hundred
thousand he still doesn't live my life
and you just got to be smart with it so
some guys are smart some guys on it I
don't want to talk to you I want to talk
to the other day he's just sitting there
he's 6-4 6-4 not introducing me so
that's okay what's up dude
yeah I was really interested in that in
and so so when money comes in the first
thing you do is you take 50 percent out
put it in a tax account the other 20
percent 25 percent are you investing
that or what are you doing with that
well when I first came out I had to I
had to take care of the be obviously
sure so my first couple years I didn't
save it all because I wanted to make
sure my mom and dad and brother sisters
were financially secure now when you get
extra money
you
invest you know people always say
investing less investin writing Wichita
so of course I've put a lot of money
like you said annuities I put a lot of
money and you know blue chip companies
companies that my Apple GE stuff like
that and then you know you try to invest
in the right business but you have to be
business minded like for example you
can't be NBA player and run a restaurant
so which means you have to you have to
do a JV with the restaurant or like for
example like if I'm gonna do a show
there's generally crazy people I'm just
gonna do a deal Steve Irwin say Steve oh
there's the money there's the concept
let's get it down rather than we have
their sticking needles and my balls and
stapling my balls hey I have a shelf
it's called pain tolerance
Steve over shake let me taste up
I give our pain I've never seen anybody
take pain like you did thank you let's
talk about your show on TNT Shaq life
man I just finished watching it I love
that I think it's very well people
always ask me how do you do so much and
how do you do everything while I
delegate like you just said and to or
just I'm just having fun taking
advantage of opportunities you know the
DJ bit is good to use the stuff is good
and it's just been a blessing and I owe
you for that
I'm here because there's two things that
get me out of my sexual life music and
laughing and muchos up when you guys had
your little one I watch it every day
every movie you may I watched it I
watched you guys have been cracked
enough when you stabled your balls to
your leg oh my god I almost pissed on
myself that was a hard and it was like
that's not really trust me I did a video
with the dude he don't mess around that
was real so thank you
they got I meant I finally met Johnny
about five years ago he was so nice so I
praising I've only met you chatting and
we man I would like yeah and you need
picked you up on his back yeah remember
that sound crazy thing is I tried to
pick him up was like picking up a
fireplug 2003 sorry 2004
I got likes I had these [ __ ] mangly
Brown messed up teeth and I went to get
I want to get my teeth fixed right so
the dentist was telling me he was your
dentist and that you came to him saying
that you wanted to get on your tooth you
said give me a tooth with the Superman
logo on it and Dennis said no I won't
let you do that I'm stumped I'm putting
my foot down I won't allow it and and he
talked you out of it yeah the head of
tooth the game I said no because no
evening he was actually good with a big
the presence of hundred thousand those
interviews of no nothing let you spend
that money so Thank You mr. Dennis
concerned about my just because people
are looking at your face it would be
distracting I think he wasn't worried
about the money I think it was like I
don't want to do that to his appearance
you know yeah I think I was coming out
of the dentist at some point and I'm
walking down I'm walking down Sunset
Boulevard and I walked right past you on
the sidewalk there was nobody around
just me and Shaq on the [ __ ] sidewalk
walking through Hollywood Jerry I
brought up the dentist at that at that
tourney that was and I think that that
was weird it was weird because you were
at the you're playing for Miami I think
at that point of course yeah when Shaq
asks you a question you listen carefully
and you answer the man honestly which of
course I did as you will see but first I
need to come clean about something that
is one of the biggest problems in my
life which is that I have lacked
discipline when it comes to stretching
so my hamstrings are always super tight
which
translates to lower back pain and my
body generally feeling like a mess which
is not okay not at my age not any age
you've got to take care of yourself so
recently I said you know what screw it I
got into stretching finally and it
helped but you know it helped even more
is this right here it's called Thera gun
okay these people from ther gun gave me
this gen fourth era gun and I'm telling
you I have been raving about it on other
people's podcasts just about how much
it's helped me I just hammer my
hamstrings with it like use it all over
I can feel life being breathed back into
my body I can feel my back problems just
going away I love this thing so much
it's ridiculous and you can try it
risk-free for 30 days if you don't like
it just send it back and they'll refund
your money but I'm telling you you're
not gonna send it back because it's that
awesome
so go to therican comm / devo Thera gun
dot-com / devo get yourself one there's
no substitute for it and it's starting
at $1.99 it's just a great price it's a
great product you'll thank me later and
right now I want to say thank you ther a
gun but let's get back to Shaq and my
uncle we always debate jumping off a
bridge and open up a bit you jump on me
because when you land that's still like
cement because if you land you can have
like you feel like like your [ __ ] is
not a virgin anymore
[Laughter]
it's not water anymore or would you jump
off the Golden Gate Bridge man that's
where people go to commit suicide so I
think I'm gonna say no
yeah
you are Superman you know if there's a
person that Superman who identifies with
the the Superman logo you know even as
DJ diesel that's you know the Superman
logo have you had any like copyright
issues where people are like you can't
[ __ ] with that actually no when I first
started out they came to me because
remember they killed Superman off I
brought back just African American
character don't steal my likeness and I
actually shot a movie with steel shot
I've had any problem I don't use it to
make money so you know me I don't say
that the Bible should matter I know I
want to say one of our mother owns a
book but you see Commons Warner Brothers
somebody owns but I got about fifty
signalman tattoos and I'm always putting
on stuff I hadn't had one of my shoes
one time he's been a dealer has they
they've always been you know super nice
that's good man okay so I know I said I
watched Shaq life on TNT
you can uh you can watch it on Hulu you
can watch it on TNT what I did I just
did it's the new Apple TV you click the
Apple TV app and and and then I search
Shaq life and it was like watch this
episode for a dollar ninety-nine now I
was like [ __ ] yeah but I did I did the
whole season for like 15 bucks or
something I'm telling you I'm not rich
like you saw I can't afford that with
Jimmy so I wonder but did this this this
Shaq live television series is just
awful news for anybody trying to make
reality TV because how many television
shows have we seen where like it's like
ah I mean dude I know you love wrestling
and and I know like like Hulk Hogan is
an American hero but I mean like for
watching like you know Hulk Hogan and
his family or plague for watching these
reality TV shows they're not do
[ __ ] and it shacks over here like doing
doing so much man it was just impressive
and we have a mutual buddy or executive
producer Rory and - oh when you were
training at the UFC gym like you put a
hurtin on Rory in that show he likes to
talk like he's a MMA attorney - no I've
been trained for 50 years I had had to
show him a couple times but what
strength and power felt like he's either
oh I'll do this they're too big or less
you and I get you there okay man and
plus he's got Samuel Jackson narrating
and that just makes it so much better
and Samuel yeah so yeah I actually I've
said what might be made to show what it
was did you know he has a voice as
everybody knows in love but he just he
just did this - like they gave him the
script and you know he probably said you
know forget the scrape on the door of my
wife there was that's know what he did
unbelievable at the beginning of the
show he says now let's be clear I don't
try to narrate TV shows but when Shaq
calls I answer it's so good man and I
really feel like you know like if
there's a theme throughout this series
it's that you're you're demanding to be
taken seriously as a DJ because you've
been DJing since 1988 and you're not
gonna be considered a novelty celebrity
DJ act and I relate to that because here
I'm known for stapling my balls to my
leg and and shoving things up my butt
but like I've been doing stand-up comedy
like legitimately doing stand-up comedy
for on tour ten years I started in 2006
but it's the real battle for me man like
I got people be like God dude he's not
he's not a stand-up comedian he's not
but he's just trying like so I relate to
that in the you know the sense of like
being known for one thing but then
establishing you
up in another area and yeah I I love it
man
I actually saw when you come these
officials on TV and I must say I was
very impressed by because one you're
funny by nature we were I don't know you
don't understand they see action no no
but when I saw that good to bones up you
know what but people do a comedy and
then the first line is that before
that's funny second line that's not a
fair and poor flyer holy [ __ ] I'm
laughing then I just kept watching like
the whole because the hard thing about
comedy we don't get him with that person
second line did you know it was the best
I could have done at that time that was
like five years ago and man like to get
to get the the Shaq seal of approval for
that five years ago man I I can't wait
for you to see my new one yeah so when
you gonna do some more crazy stuff
[Music]
jackass for I got yeah I do won't make
it happen I will text Johnny and the
director and I'll say yo Shaq wants in I
wanna I wanna box Johnny that's how I'm
a because I remember when he box
fighting the water like what I did with
my comedy I went from like telling
stories about old stuff - Tom stories
about new stuff and then so I do the the
act is about all the new [ __ ] I'm doing
and then I put it together so I do the
stand-up and I show the footage and it's
all multimedia social so do yeah I've
been dude I did I don't wanna you know
if
anybody but do one of my stunts I said
if I'm ever gonna go skydiving then the
first time I do it you know you got to
have a guy strapped on your back I said
I'm gonna be butt naked and I'm gonna be
furiously jacking off and I'm gonna and
I'm gonna time it so that when I'm
falling out of the airplane I'm blowing
alone everywhere trying to get a company
to sign up on that say oh yeah you can
do that in our plane and then trying to
find the guy who says oh yeah I'll strap
myself to your back and then trying to
get it done in an airplane full of dudes
I'm telling you that was the most
challenging stunt I've ever done and
it's not even the closer for my new tour
[Laughter]
now I'm thinking about getting breast
implants first like real big nice
titties not because I want to have
titties but because I need to know how
long I last with them before I say okay
I tap out I gotta [ __ ] get these
things off of me
like in your Keinath speedo show you
said there was kind of kind of revealing
when you were going to do this first DJ
gig in Vegas you said that you were
gonna make in 20 20 grand for the DJ gig
but that with the private jet getting
everybody there and back was like 50
grand so you were actually down 30 grand
to make that happen
look I mean I gotta you gotta view that
as an investment because when you're
really in the DJ game you're making
hundreds of grand like when you you know
so that's like an investment in the
future but but TV
are you really finding these private
jets just all everytime you go
everywhere
of course I rather rather do that than
walk through the airport tell me about
it
tell me I try to keep my feet on the
ground shack
Oh make me not I hate gone to the
airport hey Shaq can take a picture with
Jeff at checkout talk to my kid can I
see your ID
all right piss go bet you know it's like
my private so you don't have to deal
with too many people because when you do
deal with people you're the most
generous guy I love that about your show
you just say you know what I enjoy like
doing good deeds it didn't come off like
oh man he's trying to get a pat on the
back it's just like you can see that you
actually enjoy just hooking people up
like buying people's sneakers and stuff
that's what I doing well I was all about
making people smile and making people
happy like when I was in a thing was a
besom add these two little kids and the
lady told me oh man these kids come in
every day just to look at the computer
and I said why one who said no they
probably can't afford one but you know
we just let them look at I said I'll
take care of it and they give me about
I'll take care of it because they used
to be meet at point in time like this
right and just look at people's stuff
man I wish I got a car like that I wish
I can get a house I've been on what's
happening for doshu so you know I know
the kids they know who I was but you
know hopefully they use those computers
and hopefully they become a successful
one day six kids like on this show on
TNT man the family shack it's it's so
good to see you know usually as father
zero is that the protective of I always
tell people don't give me a pat on the
back for being a bit that that's how I'm
supposed to be but I appreciate it you
have kids
I don't man one of my stuff you got kids
[Laughter]
I don't know about man but one of my
stunts for my new comedy tour was called
the vasectomy Olympics and what I did
was I got a vasectomy and then I got on
a horse bareback galloping around and
then I got dressed up as a as a pinata
and I had all these kids whacking me in
the nuts of the stick yeah man it was
pretty awesome but yeah but did you
balls well yeah a plum looks purple a
purple man was coming up guys for uh
jackass for they pushed the date because
this coronavirus it was supposed to be
March of 2021 then they pushed it to
July 2nd of 2021 so I got away the whole
year killing me I'd have been like as
soon as we're shooting man like then
time time time not kidding you man like
do something when we get done I'm
reaching out Jack wants in and he wants
to box Johnny Knoxville
you also do that's so funny dude we're
both big fans of the UFC and when I saw
maybe you heard about how Justin Bieber
sends out a tweet he says you know I
want to get in the Octagon and have a
UFC fight against Tom Cruise which means
good no sense because like Tom Cruise is
55 years old Justin Bieber's like maybe
25 but I was like dude I heard that and
I got into my [ __ ] van I drove out to
Vegas and and and I got Dana White in
the van I said yo I think Tom Cruise is
afraid of Justin Bieber but I am NOT I
wanna I want to fight Justin Bieber and
knock so made fun of me for that he said
dude that's a fight that's a lose-lose
fight because if you win like
congratulations you beat up Justin
Bieber but if you
you got your ass beat by Justin Bieber
there's no way to win you just set
yourself up to lose all right so all
right so tell Johnny the first round I
want to fight him and then the second
round I want to get on my knees and
fight me man I think Knoxville is a
little bit like me fightin Bieber but
the thing is he's johnny Knoxville he's
supposed to get his ass beat so it's
perfect right yeah I'm a butter bean
made him snore again you think you can
be raised there by knocking them out of
course I can stop it Greg Hardy I love
watching that guy fight he's really good
he's really good he's actually he's
actually probably one of strongest guys
I had to face and that was it and you
know I got that wasn't like a real match
losers color like really far you know I
actually fought another band but they
didn't show up because I beat the guy
too bad but they just edited it to make
it look like me and Greg Laflamme but I
actually thought some other kid they
brought some kid and I was 250 coats in
my way and I just a Madison good only
lost to himself so cool to see you with
Ariel Helwani was a the UFC guy is good
actually
they actually told me some stuff that I
didn't know and some stuff I could never
use in a street fight I still got it
upstairs but you know the moves they
told me yeah like Jorge Mozgov that's
our buddy hey oh hey muscles it's the
real deal he's gonna be okay so he gonna
be a champ for a while I can't wait to
see his next fight I would love to see
him fight Conor I surely would I know
that they were talking about that but
dude now like Conor and just engage he
Connor Connor said Connor tweeted to
just engage he you're [ __ ] dead
because just engage he
said disrespectful things about Connor
as a father as a family man like
personal [ __ ]
so Conor McGregor's says he's gonna
knock the teeth out of just engage his
head and make a [ __ ] necklace out of
it and kill him you got stories like
that floating around that's kind of like
that makes it Connor is a good promoter
so I think it's looking good for just
engag
hmm thanks for talking to me brother I
gotta go do my other podcast I
appreciate you so much man thank you all
right look at you yeah from the bottom
of my heart thank you so much Shaq and
thank you guys for still hanging in
there you know how we do this the people
who hang in there right until the end
are the ones just I'm so grateful for
and I know that the sound wasn't the
best on this but for God's sakes it was
Shaq
so let's uh let's not worry about it too
much and in fact let's do the street
team thing and let Shaq know that that
we appreciated him doing that for us and
for the wild ride podcast yeah dude I
just I'm just super stoked man I'm super
super psyched and we're gonna keep
hitting it hard and I'm determined to go
every week no like weeks off every other
week I think really hurt the channel in
all reality I think it did
ah so let's keep the momentum going and
thank you guys for watching thank you so
so much
yeah dude